we have a voicemail number and that
number
is 2192 david p
uh here's a really nice voicemail this
is the occasional
nice voicemail um and it's from a
therapist who says
the show the david pakman show to her
is like therapy for therapists what a
nice message to send take a listen to
this
hey pac-man my name is leanna smith i
am a mental health therapist here in
charlotte north carolina
and i just wanted to reach out to you
first of all to
um commend you on the spectacular job
that you do every day
thank you when i come home from work put
on youtube
i put your show on any of your
recordings and i just come to realize
that
you are my therapy so pacman is the
therapy to the therapist
wow i just wanted to share that with you
i think that is hilarious but um
no you do actually enlighten me a lot
and i appreciate um all the viewpoints
that you share
throughout your show different aspects
on everything you um actually bring
value to a lot of the crap that's going
on in the world today so i just wanted
to send a shout out
to thank you um from charlotte north
carolina
keep doing your thing pacman wow
uh a perfect voicemail if i've ever
heard one
i really do appreciate that many mental
health
professionals are in the david pakman
show audience ranging from social
workers
to psychologists l a l mhcs
and uh psychiatrists even it's a it's a
broad range of mental health
professionals and i really do appreciate
that
we have a great bonus show for you today
it appears as though vice president
kamala harris
is going to be leading white house
efforts to stem
migration at the border what will that
look like
we also now are seeing 12 attorneys
general
calling on facebook and twitter to
remove anti-vaxxers
from their services uh where will that
go
and lastly remember how donald trump led
let that wacky right-wing network oan
into the white house that is now joe
biden's problem
and it's very interesting what is going
on so all of those stories
and more including previews of next
week's show vacation
on today's bonus show you can get
instant access to the bonus show
by becoming a member at joinpakman.com
and very important
okay we're off next week the show's not
canceled
don't worry i know that every time we
take some time off i get about a hundred
emails saying what happened there's no
show
is it canceled what we're just taking a
week off next week we'll be here
tomorrow i'll be live today for the joe
biden
press conference but next week we are
off all right so
bonus show in moments show tomorrow no
show next week